so we're going to start today with our
sort of first major results from the
2022 midterms these are primary results
and the big picture so far is relatively
unremarkable but pretty good for donald
trump in terms of his so-called track
record in endorsing people now we'll
talk about a bias to incumbency and all
these different things as we get further
in but at least for today let's start
with the few races where we had uh
elections yesterday and see what
takeaways there are in indiana there was
the republican primary in the ninth
congressional district uh not a
particularly prominent race aaron huchen
won there relatively easily over mike
cidrell
but more interestingly and a lot of
attention paid to this race so far in
the ohio us senate republican primary
j.d vance one now it's not jp
it's not j.d mandel as donald trump
claimed to endorse at his rally over the
weekend not even knowing who he endorsed
it's jd
vance jd vance winning by about seven
points over josh mandel this is the
first sort of signal about trump's
endorsement power and we can argue it's
not really the perfect example
because there were so many different
people who endorsed jd vance prominent
republicans marjorie taylor greene and
matt gates and many others but
regardless this is a situation where jd
vance was uh i believe fourth in the
polls at the point at which donald trump
endorsed him and he ultimately won 31-24
over josh mandel so that is one
interesting race now remember
uh this is the one where trump didn't
even really seem to know who he endorsed
remember this from over the weekend
that's what they're waiting for they're
waiting for one race you know we've
endorsed dr oz we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel
and he's doing great yeah uh we've
endorsed uh jp right is that who it was
uh but this is important because the
maga world or i'm hearing it now
pronounced maga by many people
including donald trump jr they're
jumping all over this and saying trump's
endorsement reigns supreme it is the
most important thing uh denouncer
distance from trump at your own peril
here is a hopped up don jr last night
shot out of a cannon making this point
remember that republicans because
there's far too many of you that forget
that and you'd rather cater to the media
the leftists the other weak republicans
so that you can be loved and invited to
the cool person party in dc
no more folks
the maga movement is a live and well and
we're witnessing it tonight
congratulations jd i know you're gonna
make us proud of the us senate
right okay so there's don jr with a shot
across the bow at anybody thinking of uh
going with the non-trump candidate i
guess or um undervaluing the important
of uh donald trump's endorsement now
remember that jd vance at one point said
that he was going back and forth as to
whether trump is america's hitler that's
what jd vance used to say he then had a
change of heart i guess and he groveled
a lot uh and donald trump ultimately did
endorse him now going back to the
results on the democratic side tim ryan
has won now tim ryan's a member of the
house currently he's been a guest on
this show before i think he's a good guy
he's a smart guy he's an impassioned
speaker for me
this is an extraordinarily important
race and of course it is now tim ryan
versus jd vance
i'm supporting tim ryan uh we will see
if we get debates there i would love to
cover those debates but this is a
particularly great race to get involved
in ryan easily winning the primary with
73 of the vote against uh two pr two
main opponents and uh that's good news
now continuing with the trump impact
over in the ninth congressional district
in ohio
as of this moment when we are taping
today's show it has not yet been called
but j.r majewski is in the lead now j.r
majewski is trump endorsed he was also a
guest on this program a few weeks ago
he was a sort of
kind of reasonable trumpist although he
still says trump won
and that 2020 was stolen and all of that
stuff but if indeed jr majewski prevails
it will be another win for donald
trump's endorsement record to the extent
that
it matters on the democratic side
disappointing to many
another attempt by nina turner
in the 11th congressional district this
is the democratic primary in ohio 11th
congressional district nina turner
losing very badly to chantal brown
now you might remember that in 2021
there was a special election between
these same candidates chantal brown and
nina turner
and in 2021 nina turner lost by six
50-44
there was the hope among many that this
time around with nina turner having more
name recognition
she would be able to pull this off she
did not she actually lost by nearly 30
points and uh sort of alluded
last night
that nina turner is running for
president in 2024
so uh
i'm not gonna do my analysis again of
nina turner's loss i did it in 2021 and
many of you agreed with it some of you
didn't and were angry with me uh but the
analysis is the same an even bigger loss
at this point in time and at this point
it doesn't even seem prudent to comment
on nina turner for president uh a lot a
lot of things have to happen between now
and then but chantal brown uh with a
very very strong victory there
uh 13 congratulat 13th congressional
district republican primary in ohio
madison gilbert won there but not by
that much
in the ohio gubernatorial primary uh
mike dewine winning relatively easily
there
and some other races that i don't think
are particularly interesting to most in
our audience there was a nashville
district attorney democratic primary i
know uh of no one in my audience who is
paying attention to that one just uh not
that it doesn't matter it's just a a
very very local race so we're keeping an
eye on a number of these races the
pennsylvania
senate race is very important that one
could ultimately decide who controls the
senate in 2023 republicans or democrats
tonight at 7 30 p.m eastern the
republicans running for pennsylvania
senate will be debating that includes
mehmet oz dave mccormick
and others and others and we'll be live
with that on youtube twitch and facebook
so i hope you will join me there and
many more primaries coming in may
all of which we will cover
do you know the fastest growing crime in
the united states for years the rate of
this crime has been surging the crime is
identity theft and it happens way more
often than you might think
it's happened to me i've talked about
this on the show before and it can be
really bad sometimes you get a text that
your email password has been changed
your bank calls about unusual activity
your paypal account is getting drained
and it can happen very very quickly to
keep my accounts protected i use aura
our sponsor aura is identity theft
protection
fraud monitoring and password management
all wrapped into one aura monitors the
dark web for your information they
monitor your credit card they monitor
your bank accounts
my subscription to aura gives me peace
of mind protects my devices it protects
all of my different accounts and i can
monitor everything in one place on the
app if i get attacked aura actually
takes action to prevent and resolve the
issues in real time and aura is letting
my audience try it completely free for
14 days go to aura.com
pacman the link is down below